hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another cobra kai season 5
interview
i've got the creators of the series john
josh and hayden i am so happy to be
talking to you yet again
congratulations on another wonderful
season
thank you thank you thank you very much
so i'm gonna warn everybody watching
this right up top we're we're just like
going into it we're going for all the
gory spoiler details so if you have not
binged season five of cobra kai this is
not the interview for you we have other
interviews that cover that kind of stuff
but this is all spoilers all right
actually before i even touch any
spoilers one thing i really wanted to
ask you guys was about the uh the
release date change and what those
conversations were like because it
seemed like you had carved out a pretty
good spot for yourself over the holiday
season so what inspired the change to
september this time around uh it was
really just a netflix ask i think they
looked at their their schedule what they
had on there and they were looking for a
big show to to drop in september and uh
they asked us to
plow into a season five as soon as we
finished making a season four so we had
no break in between uh immediately got
back from filming uh we're in we were in
post on season four and they said start
writing season five and go make it so
uh it was just uh you know a netflix ask
and uh we were having so much fun we
just dove back in with our writing staff
and got back on set
i mean and technically it's still around
a holiday weekend so
you still get that that kind of release
as well yeah i mean seasons one and two
came out i think around this weekend uh
when it originally premiered on netflix
and
i think if you look at that data that
was the the beginning of the netflix um
you know takeover of cobra kai all of a
sudden everybody knew what it was
so um it wasn't uh the most nervous ask
in terms of us
saying i don't know can it can it you
know
do okay on that weekend i think they
have enough data to look at and say you
know they they feel like it's gonna do
fine and the truth of the matter is i
feel like you guys would literally be
fine any weekend of the year
yeah you know it's it's kind of random
you know how it all happens it's the
interesting thing is you know at youtube
you know we
originally came out uh it was like
like early may of 2018 and then our
second season came out around the same
time 2019
and then with the pandemic and the
switch to netflix there was like almost
like a year and a half almost a two-year
gap so those early fans remember the the
break between seasons two and three was
really long but if you're a netflix fan
uh like josh said it came out like
around this time two years ago so
there's been like four seasons in two
years if you just jumped on the netflix
train so it's uh
you know it's kind of a little random at
times we'll we'll get to this later but
you spoiled us via netflix and now i'm
super stressed about how long the weight
could be for season six but i'll save
that for later first to get into some of
the story points here a little bit of a
broad question for you guys of
everything that we see going down in
season five what storyline would you say
changed the most from uh inception to
what we see in the finished product
nothing
yeah i think we went we always the three
of us go into a writer's room with a
a fairly firm sense of where we kind of
sort of want to
uh end the season you know we we do that
every season and it gets a little
blurrier um from season to season as the
branches of the treaty just get
you know longer and spinier um this year
i think we knew exactly where we wanted
to
end the season
there were just micro choices along the
way um you know whether you take a left
here and have to take three more lefts
to get back on the road or if you're you
know saving some of those turns for
another season but of everything that's
on the screen i don't think anything
uh changed so significantly from oh wow
i thought we were gonna do it like that
but we did it like that there are
actually some things that are visually
so close to the the hive minds um
intention of what those earliest
discussions were with our writers that
it's remarkable that we're able to kind
of keep that going and some of that is
just
how fast we wrote season five also you
know like john said we we were thrust
right back into a writer's room right
into production
and
you know it required us to have to make
some choices and stick to stick to them
in terms of we're going to do that
that's going in the outline that's going
in the script oh we're shooting that you
know in a couple of weeks and there is
something
anxious and nervous about flying without
a net sometimes but it's also kind of
invigorating that you're
you're literally creating in real time
and it's taking shape and you you have
to own it and i think to do that in the
season five is much you know easier and
more comfortable for us than doing that
in the season one or two where you're
making
such specific you know
founding
you know tenets of the show that you
everything else needs to stand on the
shoulders of um so uh yeah this one was
was an interesting one to put together
for sure okay opening it up to the whole
show to kind of build upon that a little
bit i don't know if this has ever
happened to you guys but can you give us
an example of a time when i guess you
kind of wrote yourself into a corner
didn't know how you were going to get
out of that corner but then kind of you
know put the work and the workshopping
into it and it's paved the way to
something that we get to see today it's
hard to think specifics i mean i'll just
i can kick that off by saying
we intentionally write ourselves into a
corner at the end of every season um
not not exactly knowing where we're not
going you know not not knowing where
we're not going to go but
knowing that it's a really tight you
know position to be in you know the end
of the first season chris walks in um
you know we
we knew enough about where we were going
with that but we had some really big
questions that we had to talk about
between seasons one and two
as to
what we wanted to give away right away
with crease and his backstory and
is he good is he bad um where does he
live
you know is a was a big one that we that
we talked about um so it's not entirely
writing ourselves into a corner
but it's
it's writing toward conflict you know
miguel falling off the balcony at the
end of season two with another one
that was the one that i was gonna say i
was gonna say that's the one where i
felt like we
had a sense of where we where we were
going after that but we knew that we
ended that season in a pretty crazy way
the miguel thing and also the alley
thing at the end of the season like we
were writing ally into our show through
references without having any clue
whether or not elizabeth shu was going
to do the show that's the biggest
luckily
yeah i mean yeah
luckily um it worked out and we just we
had this
like uh
attitude that we were going to
push and push and and put positivity out
into the world and hope that um she
would get excited by the creative and
want to join the party but that was the
biggest one where we were just like you
know if you build it she will come with
sort of the the mentality and there was
a there was definitely a chance that she
could have said nope not doing it and uh
that would have been that would have
been a rough one for us i'm a big
believer in that mentality i believe in
manifesting things so you guys did that
there for sure um you already brought up
cree so i am curious
what was it like when you gave marty the
scripts for season five was he like
reading reading reading and saying like
where am i in panicking we had we had to
uh you know
prepare him for this you know in advance
he we didn't just give him scripts and
and say like and and have him do that
you know we
he loves this character this world so
much and it was very difficult to tell
him that there were going to be some
episodes early in season five that he
wasn't going to be in but we just said
listen you know it it's about impact you
know and his character has tremendous
impact you know he wasn't in the first
season until the very end but that
really set up the whole show i mean like
that him coming in at the end you know
gave this amazing cliffhanger to the
first season that
gave us a second season and then it was
like oh wow now we get to explore crease
in season two and it just got to that
point where we felt in our series that
you know um taking him off the chess
board was like a big kind of soap opera
move and in these soap operas like it's
great when a character seemingly is dead
or in a coma or wherever is away and
then it's like you forget about them
just enough and then all of a sudden
they come back at the end of an episode
and it gives it you know we just told
him like it gives his character that
much more power and presence
and and you feel that like in in our
trailer like he's not in the trailer
until the very end and then he makes
that big impact and it's kind of similar
to you know what what it's like in the
seas in season five
i'll just say i remember having the
conversations with him because we knew
we were making this decision and we knew
we were gonna have to talk to marty
about it because marty loves being on
the show he loves playing this character
and we knew it wasn't gonna be a simple
easy conversation and kind of like back
when we had him come in season one and
he was lobbying to be in much earlier we
knew he was gonna lobby and all that and
i remember him being very kind of you
know frustrated with like that he wasn't
gonna be there from the beginning and i
remember saying to him i said do you
think we want to have this conversation
with you do you think like you know that
that i remember i was just like we like
we knew we were making this creative
decision that you were not going to be
thrilled with this and that we were
going gonna have to talk it through
and and and go with it but we have to
always look at the show first and
foremost and your character first and
foremost then from our like you know the
bird's eye view that we have of the
series this is gonna be a great thing
for your character your character even
though you're not present for five
episodes when you show up it's going to
be a huge surprise a big impact and
thrust you in for the rest of it and how
we end the season is going to be a huge
thing for your character so even though
you're not there from the beginning
you're going to loom large and be a huge
part of the c this season and he fully
got it like right after we had that
conversation because he knows we're
friends like he's become a really good
friend he's one of our favorite people
to hang with he's such an ambassador of
the character of the show and just a guy
who loves cinema and loves
loves what we do and and
it was uh it was definitely a tough
conversation that we knew we were going
to have and
it was predictable and and awesome in
the end because well anyone who's met
marty knows that he embodies
sensei john crease you know when he
leaves his house in the morning you know
it's where crease ends and and martin
cove begins is a very blurry gray line
so
you know when when he's being told that
you know you're not going to be in the
large part of you know the first half of
the season
he feels that so personally because it's
kind of like saying
we don't want martin cove around um and
like john said we had to separate the
two and say this is
so good for the character and it's and
some of our earliest conversations with
um you know with billy as well you know
in terms of johnny's language and
johnny's attitude because billy walks
down the street and you know for years
just like ralph does you know here's all
the catchphrases from the movie and
there is a little bit of blurred lines
in terms of you know where the
you know the human persona
ends and the character begins and
it's it's a constant conversation of
like some of these difficult
things to swallow for the character are
actually great for the character story
it was very very effective i was also
very surprised by how convincing the
stabbing scene was i was in an absolute
panic when i watched that and deep down
i i think i knew you guys would never
actually kill him off but it really got
me for a little while and that that kind
of brings me to my next question because
you have two characters that you try to
convey that they really could be dead
and then they're not so what are the
conversations like when you're working
with like a fake out death like that and
making sure that it doesn't just feel
like a device but is serving the
experience and the story overall
it just felt like we built the story to
a point where by episode 50 of this
journey there actually can be a life or
death battle and and for crease
like everything that was happening we we
earned the point where it's like they
could die
and so
and then you're like do we do that and
you know you kind of want your cake you
need it too you you want to create the
feeling of
the stakes and and have these emotional
moments
um
but at the same time we love these
characters
and so you know i think you know we
found a way you know a believable way
where you could you know in the moment
feel like oh my god was that it um but
then you know these chess pieces are are
still around to be played with um you
know we we love all these characters but
if
you know if if the death serves the
story in the best way then then we'll do
that you know with uh
with crease
you know it just felt like
you know we
we had this opportunity to make it feel
like well this would this could be like
a redemptive ending like the kind of
tragic ending of john crease like he's
finally kind of figured things out in
jail and opened himself up and now it's
like he dies by trying to stop a fight
like we could have ended it that way
um and you get to feel that for for a
moment and then he cites the he takes
the whole audience out it's like do you
really think i'm gonna have a redemption
like
well you don't get to you don't get to
do this more than more than once in the
series i think you know the the karate
kid franchise has a history of you know
having characters fake their own death
notably kris um you know so this we we
definitely wanted to
have those moments but still play with
our you know our action figures uh a
little longer um and i think
the show has also killed off characters
for real in a significant emotional way
before you know we've you know tommy
there's captain turner there's these big
moments where you know a character does
die in this series so
it is possible hopefully the audience is
feeling in those moments did that really
just happen because you know we don't
shy away from that um you know when when
we need that for an impactful
storyline or when it you know really
assists the the macro story we're
telling
but this felt like a good moment that
double fake out um to really end this
season
in a happy hopeful way um for for chosen
and in an ominous way for what does this
mean now that chris got away with this
you guys got me with both of those and
uh i can't believe the mix of emotions
that i felt in such a short period of
screen time there
somewhat in in a similar department what
were the conversations like in terms of
figuring out how much blood and like i
guess even gore to include in the new
seat you have someone's finger chopped
off so when you have a like a viewership
that spans so many age ranges how do you
figure out how far to push it in that
department
it's really just a matter of like once
you bring swords into the equation
you know like
you're it's gonna be weird for this just
do a whole sword fight and there's no
contact so we're just like
like i said like we felt like we earned
uh
this fight where like okay now we're in
the valley and there's weapons and like
chosen in silver or are out in like this
uh in
in the hills uh by a pool and and
there's a sword on sci fight going on
and you know you need to have some
amount of that and i don't know i mean
as a kid like watching star wars seeing
uh you know luke's hand get cut off and
things like that you know it's you don't
want to overdo the gore that's not what
this franchise is about but at the same
time you know you want to make it feel
like you know
when swords come out there
they you know there is the threat there
so well also johnny takes so much
punishment in that you know one-on-five
one-on-six fight
that when he does get his you know
charge up you really want to feel
that he's giving them what they're owed
uh in that moment and you know some of
that was for them to experience some of
the blood
as well okay so bringing up johnny in
that moment let's let's go to the whole
baby storyline now so with that i'm
curious what was it like figuring out
the right point in the season for miguel
and robbie to find out about that news
and also then figuring out the right way
for the two of them to react to that
because they've just been through like a
really intense uh relationship evolution
themselves so it felt to me like either
they could have done what they did in
the final show or they're just teenagers
they could have been really hot-headed
and angry about it
you know we we felt like they've been
through the ringer
uh with everything throughout the series
and you know the first half of the
season was really this journey to the
two of them finally finding common
ground
and we wanted to make the baby news
uh something that happened after
they had kind of worked things out
through their fight uh we loved the you
know
we loved making it where fighting it out
was kind of the answer and that it came
from daniel's advice to johnny in a
sense um you know unintentionally and
that it was really just them getting it
out of their system and you know we we
purposefully you know brought them to a
place where the reverse could have
happened where miguel could have kicked
robbie off of a balcony
and didn't and
in that kind of
you know shocking ex like you know deja
vu moment for both of them
they were able to see things a little
bit clearly and talk through things and
and have their
their apology and once they've sort of
like lowered the heart rate and
calmed down we love the idea of johnny
slipping and having the news slip out
and having them take it well
because you know i think you know both
those characters our characters like you
know miguel loves johnny and loves loves
his mother and you know uh earlier in
the season felt like maybe there was a
potential you know sibling that to be
had in his life when he was in his uh
journey in mexico and robbie's somebody
who's always wanted family he's been a
bit of a loner and he's had you know a
challenging relationship with his mother
who's finally kind of come around and
it's certainly a tough relationship with
johnny so
this uh you know they were in the right
headspace having sort of finally uh
exercised the demons that they have with
between each other so it felt like a
great moment for them to
uh be ready for an expanded family that
apartment complex fight between the two
of them is exceptional i know we all
love the big finale set pieces but that
was like a plus stunt work and the two
of them i just can't believe how like
much they've grown in terms of how
convincing all of their fights are but
that one really in particular blew me
away this season
yeah we're so proud of them they they
both give it you know what 100 i mean
it's
it's very rare that you have to put in
um one of their doubles unless they're
doing some sort of crazy flip and
falling from a height
they both have become just actually you
know
very well-versed martial artists who put
in the work
they want it to look good they
understand the story points they
understand their characters really well
and being able to move the camera
excuse me
move the camera in such a way that you
actually see it's both of them it helps
you stand those moments so it doesn't
feel like you know a hollywood fight
where you're on the back of a stunt
double on the back of the stunt double
you're actually following them um
through that whole journey from
downstairs to upstairs um and it was
remarkable to to see them do that and
then you know we just loved working with
our our stunt team this year in terms of
choreographing these fights in a way
that really continues to tell such a
story and a through line and and focuses
on the relationship with every you know
kick and punch every
every part of that fight is intentional
in terms of calling back something
that's happened in in their relationship
calling back a specific moment from
their balcony fight um it's it's all
kind of boiling over and and we want the
audience to feel that you want to feel
like uh oh is this the the ultimate
payback that's going to lead to even
more tragedy
always one of the strongest elements of
the show and it just gets better and
better every season i'm always very
impressed by that actually i guess
that's a good excuse to bring up the
finale fight because
you you guys set a really high bar with
how you want to end your seasons with
this huge fight with so many of the
characters but then you leave yourself
with the pressure to keep raising the
bar like you want to give fans what they
know they got in previous seasons but
you also need to make it different and
show them something new so what were the
conversations like with this particular
finale fight in terms of how you wanted
to do that but also make it different
well i just remember in season four
talking to thomas and griffith and him
being like you know i'm really good with
the sword you know um
and that's i remember i remember
remembering that and
you know just going into season five we
were just like okay like daniel's
bringing in chosen you know chosen as
the type of person who is willing to
kill people like we as we saw in in
crowded kid 2 like you know that that
sequel took it to that life or death
place
um and
you know we we just like the idea of
like raising these stakes so that you
know by the time you're reaching the
season finale you do feel this sense
that like wait is somebody gonna die
over this you know like but but you
understand why if you if you've been on
the journey um and you know it's it's
it's a little bit like star wars where
these th these different fronts that are
happening at the same time uh in the war
so you have the kids in the dojo you
know having this all-out skirmish while
trying to get information on terry
silver you have a terry silver uh sword
on size fight you have johnny taking on
the fist uh in in the mansion there and
then it all comes back to a classic
silver daniel rematch um it's a lot of
fighting it's it's a lot and it's
amazing how we're able to cram you know
this stuff in you know it's our longest
episode
and you know it's it's just uh it's the
payoff of the season and when you have
so many characters there's lots of
payoff and it ends up becoming you know
just a very long episode but it's
non-stop action we have a few more
tricks up our sleeve for
where we go from here but it does get
bigger every year and we're trying at
all times to make sure we're not
plagiarizing ourselves at this point you
know we've had tournament fights we've
had all out you know riots um we've had
fights on multiple you know you know
platforms and places in terms of you
know season season three you know had
had multiple fights going on um you know
within one episode this is probably the
most wall-to-wall fighting we've had in
a finale um and we wanted to make sure
we were containing that you know once
again with these moments that you really
feel you want to feel every
one-on-one every two on one every 10 on
10 um
it's it's always conducting the
orchestra and feeling you know when do
the cannons go off and it's full
tchaikovsky fireworks and when is it you
know a uh an oboe solo that's that's
just kind of giving you different kinds
of feels the f the fun part about this
season's finale though is that like it's
all ignited by drunkenness it's it's
just like are all the villains of karate
kid two three you know like uh one two
and three are just like you know what's
[ __ ] this let's just go over and beat
the crap out of him like in a
belligerent drunk state and like they go
off and do that and it just it starts
this chain reaction of craziness does
does your new show have anything to do
with that i know there's like a drunken
element to that that storyline too
oh our new our new show is a whole other
kind of beast it's uh
this that our new show is not something
that you bring the the families to i'll
say that it's it's a it's a throwback to
all the kind of work that we did before
cobra kai
uh but in such a uh
in our belief a revolutionary way for
television you don't you don't see those
big uh you know r-rated summer
blockbuster comedies come out in
theaters that much anymore and uh
obliterated is kind of the
uh tv equivalent of that but with the
with the
the huge with an r-rated you know
blockbuster action adventure also on top
of it yeah that's that's what i was
saying i was about to say that it's uh
it's the throwback to those action
movies of our youth as well that it's
all all of our uh skills thrown in one
blender and that's what obliterated is
so it's been it's this is it's a wild
one it's so much fun and it's it's gonna
surprise people i like it all right now
is when panic mode sets in because i
have to let you guys go soon a couple
questions that i don't even know if
you'll be able to answer but the saikai
thai guy is that still in play is that
where miyagido is if it's even called me
agido well well we know uh we know that
that it's happening we now know that
this is the the biggest tournament in
the world and uh
you know uh daniel and and johnny and
chosen uh you know have an entry point
in there and and cobra kai also does but
we don't know what's happening with
cobra kai right now
um and yeah we just love the idea of
you know constantly raising the the bar
and and the levels and you know uh like
you said earlier our our the kids on our
show are now next level martial artists
um so they need they need a bigger
challenge and and they will get one um
but how that all plays out uh we'll
we'll we'll see should i push pause on
buying any more merch like am i going to
get a new name soon and then meet all
that merch
no this it's it's a constant merch
train you know you need to have every
level of the cobra kai each season
there's there's new merch so it's really
just the whole purpose of the show is
just the merch i wish we had a bigger
cut in it or any cut in it yeah i mean
we should own tattoo parlors at this
point for all the hawk cover-ups that
people are probably trying to get you
know
honestly i can't even imagine um here's
another crease question for you if kris
escapes and he's on the run how
dangerous can he be because i'm assuming
he can't open another dojo so what
weapons does he have to contribute to
whatever fight is happening
i'll just say he's been in war god of
anybody in the series right now
crease is the most dangerous character
because
he has nothing to lose and he hates
everybody um and he feels abandoned by
you know the the only person that he was
trying to help
um in his own twisted way so
i would never
count him out in terms of what he's able
to to pull off um in terms of what he's
able to risk it's like everything the
season ends in a way where it's like did
we do it is it's over we we
cobra kai's done and yet there's this
guy who just got out of jail who like
wants to kill everybody you know like
right there it's like maybe there's a
way that like he'll just relax and not
he doesn't have to deal with revenge and
maybe it'll just be a peaceful rest of
the way we'll see how we play it
i know kris has always said that peace
time is just a lull between battles so
yes we'll see it might be peace time
right now and we'll find out if it just
remains peace time
like karate witness protection and and
the show just kind of ends i don't think
marty would approve of those scripts
no
[Music]
i'll end with this one i know you guys
are juggling a lot and this makes me
feel very greedy but can you give us any
kind of sense of the writing and
production timeline for season six how
how much can we expect to wait for new
content
we can't give you any specific timelines
yet um but um we
you know we are always thinking we are
always writing you know the three of us
you know we've said it before we we are
attached to the brain we live together
during production we're living together
right now as we're in production on
obliterated um our cobra kai brains have
never stopped um so even when we're not
in the writers room we are making plans
we are moving forward and as soon as
there is you know a a date to share or a
timeline to share we will absolutely do
it you don't want to share it like right
now right here
i don't think i'm allowed the cool thing
is the new show that we're doing
obliterated is with netflix and sony and
and they're great with like saying hey
you know what
give this show obliterated like that
that cobra kai season one kind of
treatment and and that's what we're
doing right now but
we you know we're all about you know
making sure that you know we're back in
cobra kai asap it's really important for
netflix and
uh and and we can't not think about it
so it's uh
it'll come maybe not you know as soon as
everybody wants but it'll it'll come all
right i'll take that i feel like that's
a fair response i approve of this
timeline now you guys can get back to
work on obliterated i have to let you go
thank you so much for your time today
and yet again huge congratulations and
thank you for another great season of
cobra kai it is always a major bright
spot in my tv viewing and i really
appreciate it thank you perry thank you
you